Trascrizione: Silvia Colombo
Revisore: Denise RQ
Buon pomeriggio a tutti.
A mio parere c'è sempre l'idea
che le crisi
soffrano di pessima reputazione.
Al contrario, credo che,
alla mia modesta opinione,
dovrebbe essere il contrario.
Dovrebbero essere celebrate
e in un certo senso anche considerate
qualcosa di molto positivo.
Quella frase in effetti racchiude questa
idea della crisi,
cioè l'idea che le crisi molto spesso
portino a cambiamenti.
Quindi c'è l'idea di non seguire più
cose che magari ci legano al passato
o che sono state fatte
per tantissimo tempo.
Quindi c'è un cambiamento socio-culturale
o politico e così via.
Ovviamente, un esempio molto chiaro
in relazione all'idea della crisi
è quello della famiglia.
Se in questo momento
si chiedesse a un bambino
o magari a un bambino
che vive "in the Western world"
di disegnare la propria famiglia
ovviamente il disegno avrebbe un papà,
una mamma,
magari un fratello o una sorella
e, se ci sono, anche dei cani
o dei gatti che a casa vivono con loro.
Ma se si chiedesse a questi bambini
tra un po' di anni di disegnare
la propria famiglia,
sarebbe completamente diverso.
Questi due bambini sono dei "twiblings".
"Twiblings" è un nuovo termine
del dizionario contemporaneo
che è formato dalla parola
"twins" e "siblings",
quindi da "gemelli"
e da "fratelli" o "sorelle"
e nasce
in relazione alle nuove tecnologie
che vengono utilizzate
per la fecondazione artificiale
oppure l'utilizzo di "surrogates",
delle persone che portano
avanti gravidanze per altre persone.
Loro sono dei "twiblings",
perché questa coppia,
lei seduta e lui sul lato destro,
ha deciso di avere un bambino.
Però purtroppo lei non poteva
portare avanti la gravidanza,
quindi hanno scelto una donna,
pagandola per portare avanti la gravidanza
utilizzando un ovulo che veniva da lei.
Poi si sono detti: "Facciamo un bambino.
Perché non ne facciamo due
allo stesso tempo?"
Quindi hanno pagato un'altra donna
e hanno avuto due bambini
allo stesso momento da due donne diverse.
E da quello deriva il termine "twiblings".
Quindi la cosa diventa un po' complicata.
Chiedendo a loro di disegnare la famiglia
il disegno
che abbiamo visto precedentemente
sarebbe completamente diverso,
perché inizi ad avere delle persone
che sono socialmente magari
non legate a loro,
però che biologicamente
magari hanno delle relazioni
che sono un po' diverse
da come le intendiamo
nella dinamica in cui viviamo
in questo momento
e con cui la famiglia
viene considerata in questo momento.
La stessa cosa se si chiedesse
alla bambina nella fotografia
di disegnare la propria famiglia.
In Romania, la donna sul lato destro
è considerata forse una delle donne
più anziane che è riuscita
ad avere una gravidanza molto tardi,
se ricordo bene a 67 o 68 anni.
Ovviamente se si chiedesse a lei
di disegnare la propria famiglia,
nuovamente, sarebbe completamente diversa.
Ed è la stessa cosa per Ian Mucklejohn,
una persona molto ricca in Inghilterra
che voleva avere dei figli,
ma non voleva avere una relazione
con una donna,
perché aveva paura che magari
se ci fossero stati dei problemi di litigi
e così via ci sarebbe stato il problema
dei bambini: dove andare, a chi darli.
Quindi ha deciso di andare su Internet
e utilizzando un sito,
come magari si fa
per acquistare altre cose,
ha comprato un ovulo, ha scelto una donna.
Lui è in Inghilterra, queste persone
erano in America
e dopo nove mesi
sono nati tre bambini, "triplets".
La cosa interessante di questo
è che il modo
in cui vengono fatte queste cose
è quasi come acquistare un'autovettura.
Si scelgono: il colore degli interni,
il colore dell'esterno,
la cilindrata e così via.
Se si va su uno di questi siti,
inizialmente si sceglie la tipologia,
per esempio, siccome questo è in America,
si può scegliere lo Stato
da cui la persona proviene,
la razza oppure il tipo di religione.
Una volta fatta la prima scelta,
ci sono varie persone "shortlisted",
in base ai profili
che sono stati scelti all'inizio.
Poi se clicca su una di queste persone
c'è un profilo molto più completo
con delle cose registrate per la voce,
oppure legate all'educazione,
al tipo di aspirazioni
che hanno e così via.
Qui per esempio
c'è il prezzo del donatore.
Ovviamente se la persona
ha già donato degli ovuli
che hanno contribuito alla nascita
di un bambino o di una bambina,
costa molto di più.
È una questione di mercato.
E poi ci sono delle cose
ancora più interessanti.
Questa è un'azienda in America
che si chiama California CryoBank.
Qui hanno un programma
che si chiama "Donor Look-Alikes".
Hanno una "databank" di donatori di sperma
che assomigliano a persone famose
quindi è possibile scegliere
in questa lista
per esempio lo sperma di una persona
che assomiglia a Bill Gates
oppure a Danny DeVito.
Ed è una cosa abbastanza interessante
dal profilo socio-culturale.
Uno si chiede per quale motivo
uno debba scegliere.
Però fondamentalmente
ci dà la possibilità di scegliere cose
che in un certo senso ad alcune persone
fanno anche piacere.
Ed è una cosa interessante
dal profilo dell'idea di pensare,
cioè di distinguere le due cose:
consumatore e cittadino.
Come cittadini
noi in effetti facciamo delle critiche,
ci interessiamo a cose,
magari ci arrabbiamo e così via,
partecipiamo a dibattiti...
Però come consumatori
molto spesso siamo irrazionali,
quindi le cose che facciamo
come consumatori
sono molto diverse
dalle cose che facciamo come cittadini.
E queste cose sono interessanti
nel contesto della crisi,
perché ovviamente poi bisogna pensare
alle due cose in modo parallelo.
Come designer, una delle cose
che ho cercato difare nell'ultimo decennio
è quella di avvicinarmi a temi,
come in questo caso,
della famiglia e del cambiamento
della famiglia più che altro in crisi.
Perché mi piacerebbe pensare
all'idea della famiglia
che cambia,
piuttosto che alla famiglia in crisi.
Come designer, ho sviluppato delle idee
in relazione a queste varie aree.
Una delle varie cose che ho pensato
nel contesto dell'idea del "surrogate",
cioè dell'idea che c'è una donna
magari in un altro Paese
che porta avanti la gravidanza
per una coppia,
una persona che ha pagato quella persona.
Una delle cose che non puoi fare
a distanza è controllare se la persona
per esempio fuma o mangia delle cose
che non fanno bene oppure beve.
Ci sono delle cose che magari fa
che potrebbero danneggiare
la salute del bambino.
Questo è un servizio che dà la possibilità
alla persona che porta avanti gravidanza
di mettere un cerotto digitale,
che registra la fisiologia della persona.
Quindi a distanza è possibile controllare
se la persona beve alcol, fuma
o fa delle cose che potrebbero danneggiare
la salute del bambino.
Un'altra idea: ovviamente
quando la gravidanza è nella stessa casa
c'è un rapporto molto diretto
tra i genitori, le persone che sono lì.
Quindi c'è il contatto quotidiano
con la mamma in gravidanza.
Ci sono moltissime persone
che parlano alla pancia,
al bambino che è all'interno della donna.
Addirittura suonano anche della musica
che magari potrebbe piacere a loro.
Ovviamente se sei a distanza
questa cosa non puoi farla.
In questo caso, utilizzando questo oggetto
e mettendo questo apparecchio
sulla pancia della donna
si ha la possibilità di parlare ala pancia
e di suonare la musica preferita
e mandarla a questa persona
che magari vive in un altro Paese.
La terza idea sono dei giocattoli
che vengono utilizzati.
Uno è una pancia, l'altro è uno sperma
e l'altro è un ovulo.
In relazione a come vengono utilizzati,
si può spiegare ai bambini
come sono nati e come la famiglia
è stata costruita in relazione
a come vengono utilizzati tra di loro.
E mi piacerebbe terminare
con questa "quote" di Wells,
un "science fiction writer", che dice
que la crisi di oggi è
la barzelletta di domani.
Grazie.
(Applausi)